orléans et la loire une longue histoire
d'amour et de crainte mêlée les craintes
ses crus ravageuse et imprévisible
l'amour parce que la loire fut longtemps
l'artère économique de la france et
orléans une étape incontournable
les quais immense témoigne d'une intense
activité aujourd'hui révolue des bateaux
partout des mariniers dans tous les sens
des gars qui cherche qui déchargent des
gars qui s'arrêtent qu'ils boivent un
coup des gars qui vendent qui achètent
et c est une population sur les quais du
châtelet énorme il faut imaginer jusqu'à
10000 bateau qui passait ici du temps de
l'essor de la marine de loire au 18e
xviiie siècle et puis c'était jusqu'à
dix mille bateaux donc pendant l'année
marinière et l'année marinière c'est pas
tout le temps c'est quand il ya de l'eau
dans la loi et quand il ya de l'eau dans
la loire c'est l'automne jusqu'à la fin
du printemps et la arrivait jusqu'à 300
mille tonnes de marchandises mais on
n'imagine pas c'était énorme
bertrand et mariniers par passion il
nous invite à bord de la sttr
passé le pont de chemin de fer le
bruxellois rapidement le paysage semble
redevenir calme et sauvage enfin sauvage
entendons-nous le fleuve royal est
endiguée endiguée et entretenu jusqu'au
début du 19e siècle période où le train
a supplanté la marine de loire
on était sur une autoroute pour la
batellerie et depuis la marine de loire
s'est arrêté eh ben la nature a repris
ses droits on a des arbres partout alors
qu'ils ne bloquent le vent mais surtout
qui en cas de crue majeure on n'est pas
sûr du tout qui reste simple et riza les
s'empiler dans les ponts
si on à l'accumulation d'orages sur les
montagnes de pleine lune avec grandes
marées qui freinent l'évacuation de
l'eau aussi emballant période de marée
haute pour ses rares mais il n'empêche
qu'au xviiie et au 19ème s'en fout quand
même tapé à tacler
les crues sont liés à la capacité
d'écoulement du fleuve sans entretien
cette capacité s'amoindrit ainsi les
arbres ralentissent les écoulements
retiennent le sable provoque
l'apparition deal qui rehaussent le
niveau d'eau et augmentent ainsi le
risque d'inondation
il ya eu du passage de
de bulldozer l'a régulièrement il ya de
l'entretien qui est fait
pour bébé et alizée un petit peu
d végétalisée une solution pour
permettre au sable accumulé de s'écouler
libérant de l'espace pour le lit de la
loire permettant aussi d'abaisser le
niveau de l'huile qui sera ainsi plus
facilement immergé en cas de montée des
eaux
cette opération appelée plan loire
grandeur nature est financé par l'état
et la région dans le respect du paysage
remarquable classé au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco
bah navigables mais toujours navigué
c'est ainsi que la batellerie définit la
loire une loi rebelles dangereuse qui
demandait beaucoup au maroc
on n'imagine même pas on est on est des
rigolos on est rigolo on a des moteurs
on a des techniques aujourd'hui on élit
rigaux les mecs si je sais moi je ne
sais pas comment il faisait et ça devait
être un truc un métier une paire rude
dangereux c'était priorité à la
manoeuvre
voilà des trucs de fou
nous arrivons sur comble un lieu
important dans l'histoire du commerce de
loire où les cas nous prenait le relais
pour acheminer les marchandises à paris
et plus loin encore par le réseau des
canaux européen comble c'est la plaque
tournante c'est la jonction entre la
loire et le canal est donc c'est après
le chemin de la rivière c'est le même
canal qui va pouvoir permettre de
remonter les marchandises à travers la
forêt d'orléans jusqu'au canal du loing
du loin à la scène et de la scène
descendre la scène pour arriver à paris
dans les années 90 un regain d'intérêt a
permis une activité fluviale à vocation
touristique
la loire véritable réserve naturelle se
visitent s'observe depuis le pont des
bateaux reconstruit
la nouveauté est là le fleuve n'est plus
seulement vu depuis la berge mais aussi
vécu et cela lui confère une place
particulière dans le paysage
émotionnelle de ces riverains